Okay Michael, so here's our second ,quiz, is
a row. In the last quiz, we talked about
running time and space time, but now we're going to
talk about ,how the k-nn algorithm, actually works. And
in particular how different choices, between distance metrics, values
of k, and how you're going to put them together,
can give you different answers, okay? So, what I
have over here on the left is training data.
This is a regression problem and you're training
data is made up of xy pairs. X is
two dimensional. Okay? So this is a function
from R squared to some value in R1. Okay?
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, the first dimension represents, something
and the second dimension, represents something. And then
there's some particular, output over here. And what I want you to do, is given a
query point, 4, 2 produce what the proper y or output
ought to be, given all of this training did. You're with me?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, so I want you to do it in four different cases, I
want you to do it in the case where, your distance matrix is euclidean, Okay.
>> The distance metric, in R2?
>> Yes.
>> Oh I see because, we're going to measure the distance
between the query and the different data points.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Okay. Uh-huh.
>> Mm-hm. So it's euclidean, for a case of one
nearest neighbor and three nearest neighbor and I want you
to take, for example, in the three nearest neighbor case.
I want you take their output and average them. Okay?
>> Okay.
>> Now, in the I also want you to do the same thing. But in the case
where instead of using Euclidean distance, we use Manhattan
distance. But again, for both 1 nearest neighbor and
3 nearest neighbor And in any case where
we have ties, like in three nearest neighbor where
we absolutely have to have at least three of
these things show up, just let 'em average. Okay?
>> Got you.
>> Now we're doing averaging instead of
straight voting, because, this is a regression problem.
>> Got it.
>> Okay. Any questions?
>> Maybe. Let's see. Three nearest neighbor. And so if there's ties, we, we
use the college ranking trick of including
everybody who's at least as good as the
k, largest or k closest.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> Okay, yeah, no I think, I think I can take a stab at this.
>> Okay, cool then go.